we're gonna be building these cabins on
the woods we're gonna need a generator
generators are so loud it obnoxious you
could go to the store and buy a
generator that is insulated and it's
very quiet but those run you upwards of
$3,000 for one of those little
generators that puts out the same power
this thing was three hundred and ninety
nine dollars I've always wanted to build
a generator house to make the sound less
and I'm gonna finally do it today a lot
of the stuff I taught myself how to do
I'm learning as I go definitely listen
to me at your own discretion and your
own peril okay so we're gonna need some
insulation crusher treated plywood 1/2
inch or 3/4 inch a straight edge or a
level some flashing your drill you're
framing gun two-by-sixes nails screws
pencils utility knife duct tape and a
circular saw basically the house is
gonna consist of walls and a little roof
the walls are made of 2 by 6 the roof
and the walls are also made of pressure
treated plywood so it can withstand the
elements this little house is gonna be
completely insulated and sealed except
one side is gonna be removable so you
can slide the generator out fill it with
gas and start it up again and then
you're gonna slide it back in and seal
it up you have to find out which side
sucks in the air the way you do it is
you fire it up and basically I feel like
to take this is pretty sophisticated I
like to take a piece of paper and use
that piece of paper to help me determine
where it's sucking and where it's
blowing
that's where it sucks
that's where it blows the first thing
that you're gonna do you need to build
walls for your generator this is basic
framing you've got studs going up and
down and you got plates top and bottom
going across like that here's one of the
walls I've gotten that just by measuring
the side of my generator right here
these little Stuber walls are going on
the inside in between the longer walls
I'm gonna nail this little Stuber into
this right here what make what we call a
Cali El actually that's probably not the
right turn don't quote me on that
Cali yeah or is this a Kalia Kalia now
that I've got this in the right place
and it's I don't have to hold it up and
do some crazy stuff cuz I got that brace
right there I'm gonna nail in this side
I know that this is the base and we
don't want this nice untreated fur
sitting on the ground of the forest
because you'll get wet and abroad so
what we need to do is cut a piece for
this to be able to sit on I'm gonna go
cut that out of pressure-treated plywood
and screw it to the bottom here not this
one because this is a removable one I'm
gonna put the piece of plywood on a just
screw to this part this part in this
part now again remember this is a
generator cabin this does not have to be
perfect okay this needs to serve a
function the function is to quiet down
the generator and not rotten to the
ground in the meantime if you're on the
internet people have definitely tell you
you're a hack but those that come
through and see your generator how to do
like dude what you were a quarter-inch
guy this piece of sheathing is going to
be 36 inches long 21 and a quarter
inches tall 36 by 21 you're gonna get
two of those those are the walls for our
generator house generator cabin safety
goggles are cool because you don't want
to go blind
building a generator cabin or any other
kind of cabin
the first screw is always the hardest
that sounds like a Rod Stewart and I'm
gonna just put screws in all the studs
all the plates every like four inches to
remember we didn't attach the fourth
wall because this is how the generator
is gonna slide in and out we have the
other piece of plywood and we're gonna
put it on I'm only gonna screw to these
studs this plate in this plate I'm
making sure not to screw to these ones
over here otherwise I won't be able to
remove the wall and you gotta remove the
wall okay did I screw to the thing I
told you not to screw to no I thought I
did though let's see if I'm right okay
BAM
so now when we want to service our
generator turn it on add gas add oil we
have a wall that removes we'll put a
little handle right here so you can pull
it pull it down and pull it out next
step cut a hole for the exhaust and a
hole for the ins aust I don't know what
that word is someone let me know what's
the opposite of exhaust in sauce I know
that we're gonna be using this end of
the generator more than this end this
end you really only use to get the gas
so we want this end to be the end that
is closest to the door that opens up or
the wall that opens up on the generator
cabin on the intake I'm gonna measure
the diameter that we need the intake
port to be and I'm also going to measure
from the side in the bottom where the
center of that is going to be to make
the exhaust port and the intake port
we're gonna use some metal flashing with
a utility knife you can just cut this
you score it okay and then bend it back
and forth and it popped right off like
that we take a piece of duct tape start
with it little pieces and then go over
with a nice fatty beau fatty piece
now I'm gonna take my Opie's what we're
even gonna wrap it this is called duct
tape and what we've made it basically a
duct here's where the center line is
gonna be like the whole you get that
about centered and now I'm gonna trace
this hole now I take my sounds off so
here's our intake hole so when you open
it up that's where the intake is going
to sit update make sure that you make
the exhaust port on your generator cabin
way bigger than that two-inch one that I
told you to do before the exhaust port
wasn't exactly lined up where it should
be so that heat was just bouncing around
inside our generator cabin overheated
the generator the generator started to
get a vapor lock stopped working so what
I did is I came back here and I just cut
in a big old like two foot by two foot
hole the whole back wall exposed the
whole back of the generator so that all
that heat is escaping I got my sharp
knife I got my installation now with
this stuff wow this is compressed so I
can cut it easier I start to cut really
lightly and make sure I've cut through
all the paper see that all the papers
been cut now I press down tight just go
a couple of light cuts and then you get
a nice little piece like that after it's
been insulated we built these little
rafters you don't want to do just a flat
board because the rain will just pull up
on it so you have to you want to have at
least a little bit of pitch to it and
that's why I just took a 2 by 6 I went
to the middle and I went up three and a
half inches and I connected the dots
there 15 inches apart so when I take the
insulation
I pop it in so the paper is on the
bottom side where the generator is at so
none of this falls down into the
generator we've got the roof boards one
goes on there one goes on right you're
lashing right here so the rain doesn't
get in there seal up the side so this
doesn't become a mouse cabin then we're
good to go so let's do those things fire
it up
see if it works make sure that it's
still exhausting out the back it's still
sucking it in oh yeah is it quieter
what's up now we've got a generator
that's nice and quiet like I like my
classroom it works can you believe it
work
stay tuned next time for more things I
think I know how to do and I might think
of some more to share with you
[Applause]
it's double-paned soundproof lat
there's no way that he could have been
murdered please be sure to LIKE and
subscribe this channel so you never miss
an update and please back us on patreon
so we can keep these free videos coming
yes free ain't free we need you back us
please